hey what is up guys mkbhd here and today
we're talking about a phone a phone that
is taking the internet by a storm very
recently since it was announced and
revealed it's the one plus
now to clarify it's the company name is
oneplus and the phone name is the one
now i don't physically have the phone
yet but uh i figured i'd address it
anyway because so many people have asked
about this phone and for good reason
it's seriously impressive uh but for the
actual hands-on footage there's a
channel called android authority and
josh over there makes excellent videos
he actually did get to spend some time
in person with this phone so the
hands-on footage is from him and i'll
link that right below the like button if
you want to check out the entire video
so why is everyone talking about this
oneplus one
i was teased a lot by this chinese
manufacturer oneplus it's a relatively
new company not really too sure what to
expect to them
turns out it has really nice specs so
it's rocking a 5.5 inch 1080p display it
has a 13 megapixel back facing 4k camera
of 5 megapixel front-facing camera the
2.5 gigahertz quad-core snapdragon 801
the adreno 330 gpu three gigs of ram a 3
100 milliamp hour battery to power it
all clearly this thing is firing on all
cylinders in a spec department now
before it was revealed it was all hyped
from oneplus about these no compromise
beastly specs but we didn't actually get
to see the design of it so now that it's
actually been revealed we also get to
see how it's packaged what the design
looks like and it does look pretty nice
now again i haven't held the device in
person but you can see here from josh's
videos it looks like it fits in the hand
pretty well again it's a big 5.5 inch
display so it's a decent sized body
similar to the oppo fine 7a that i
revealed and it's got some solid build
materials so it appears to be as well
built as the oppo at least that's what
it looks like from the videos we have to
watch
there's also some other videos from
oneplus about its construction and you
can see it has a slightly curved design
and a bit of a tapered back to make it
feel thinner
and it doesn't have any weird protruding
bits of the camera or anything so it's
pretty compact and it looks like the
back will actually be replaceable at
least in the near future to let you
choose from a bunch of back materials
later like a sort of a do-it-yourself
moto maker and what's cool is underneath
the hood on the software side you're
going to get a custom version of
cyanogenmod called cyanogenmod 11s and
because this is custom it's built
specific for this device so this
partnership will let them use unique
cyanogenmod features like data
encryption and the new camera app and it
also gives you the ability to switch
between software and hardware capacitive
buttons on the fly so you can choose
which one you want whenever you want
with a single switch in the settings
that's the first and as far as i can
tell no other phone lets you do that so
that's an advantage to working with
cyanogen on a custom os for your phone
plus i'm sure there will be many more
features like that but the most
impressive thing about the oneplus one
and the real reason so many people are
talking about it is the price
so this phone comes in a 16 and 64
gigabyte version the 16 gigabyte version
which only comes in white will be 299
and the 64 gigabyte version which only
comes in black will be
349 dollars which means they only went
up by 50 going from 16 gigabytes to 64
gigabytes unlike some other
manufacturers so compared to other
phones that is insane and compared to
other high-end phones with similar specs
like this that's even more insane our
our beloved nexus 5 which sells in the
google play store uh is 16 gigabytes for
349 that is a really good price for this
high-end phone and that undercuts a lot
of the other high-end phones like the
galaxy s5 and the htc one this one plus
one
undercuts the nexus 5. for the price of
one 64 gigabyte iphone 5s you can get
two 64 gigabyte one plus ones and have a
hundred and fifty dollars left over for
whatever so yeah the fact that they're
able to get that insane screen the 5.5
inch display the awesome specs and the
great camera and big battery all in a
phone for this low of a price has a lot
of people talking of course the natural
question is
why is it so cheap you know is it is
what's the catch what's the trade off is
it gonna fall apart in two years is
there a design flaw something we don't
know about uh it's just really
mind-blowing to a lot of people that it
can be the same specs as the galaxy s5
and htc one and be half the price so of
course if you couldn't tell i am really
curious to get my hands on this device
and review it in full detail and show
you guys everything i can on the site it
says available in q2 so that's already
uh now so hopefully it should be on sale
very very soon and uh i would i would
keep an eye on the uh the oneplus site
and the oneplus twitter of course if
they're sending out review units
so what do you guys think is this the
real uh flagship killer that they're
saying it is um i'm i don't know i just
i'm excited to see it i'm i'm hesitant
because i don't know how they got it
down to this price when the one m8
continues to be 600 bucks but
i'm excited i'm definitely excited to
see it so let me know what you guys
think in the comment section below and
thanks for watching this video this
quick video and i'll talk to you guys in
the next one
peace
do
you